[Music]
guys thank you for thank you for staying
with us
uh we have a guest and I actually uh I
met her on Chrissy Marsh show which was
a lot of fun uh content creator and
professional butter eater that's right
Lenny Mack
thanks for having me thank you for being
here yeah it was uh it was nice meeting
you on Chrissy Mars I think Chrissy Mars
bringing people together forever oh
she's amazing she has introduced me to
so many amazing people I love her so
much she won't invite Marsha on the show
it's such a crazy show that I don't even
remember being on it oh yeah it's so
funny because okay so here's the thing
the first time I did Chrissy's show
she's like I hope you're not mad at me
because I had mershon before you and I'm
and I didn't know I was like remember
she never told me he was on her show so
then I but I don't want to look an idiot
I go oh that's don't worry about it I
don't care and then Marsha's like I was
never on her show yeah like we were
doing a pre-show meeting and he's like
when were you on Chrissy Mayer shows and
she said you were on and I'm like I've
never been on her show I did one comedy
show with her 12 years ago at the
brokerage on Long Island oh okay and
that's like but I'm like I doubt she she
really just I think just thinks I've
been on I guess yeah well she doesn't
like you she likes me that's fine it's
fine
by the way I am also on keto so I do
enjoy eating sticks of butter I just
want to be clear I am I'm really
I already have IBS and I feel like it
would all slide out oh keto will help
you a lot with that my sister-in-law she
had Crohn's disease like struggled with
that for a long time and then she went
keto lost 50 pounds her Crohn's has been
in remission for months now so it's
amazing but like I gotta ask like why
the butter though oh
high fat macros I
way to up my fat macros it's just eating
butter which is pure fat we should
rename our show that merch high fat
Macross
high fat Mac Bros there you go I love it
I love it so yeah you don't just eat mac
and cheese
yeah and Big Macs all right I like it oh
man I'm hungry
um I can't have carbs it's fine but uh
yeah so you did that and obviously that
hat look you stand out that's that's why
you blew up because seeing somebody talk
eating butter and like talking about
things that actually kind of matter a
little bit is right you know you know
what it works you know you sell the
sizzle not the steak right I'm like more
familiar with you on Twitter so like I
like I follow you on Twitter and I've
seen some of your stuff and I'm like oh
she's coming on that's cool and I had no
idea like Royce just reminded me as we
were going live he's like you know have
you ever seen a video like the chick
eating butter and I'm like oh wait
that's her too I don't even know all
right yeah
always happens people know me as the
butter girl and then some people know me
just for the gaming stuff or the the
like current event stuff going on on
Twitter and then uh I think it kind of
blows their minds when they're like wait
this is all the same person now I just I
just know what it is the hot chick on
Twitter that's like hey ladies stop
being [ __ ] [ __ ] actually you know
why stop being pieces of [ __ ]
I was like she's pretty
I'm thinking you need a cool catchy name
butter babe that's not a bad one butter
babe I like it no you're right because
Melanie Mac's really hard that's not
marketable at all no but butter baby
nobody's ever gonna remember that
so hard I don't want to be ashamed of my
own show I don't like that it makes me
feel bad butter girl makes her sound
like one of those like we're like back
when they do like like Howard Stern
right now oh yeah we're bringing butter
girl on hey guys did you watch that
butter Gold Video on ogre it was crazy
hey guys we're gonna put a butter in a
balloon wait wait a second wait a second
Melanie how old are you I need to know
if you're getting our references how old
are you I'm 35. okay she's definitely
getting our references you're not 35 I'm
not trying to be a dick but no you're
not shut the [ __ ] up Jesus man I look
like [ __ ] I look like garbage [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and you're on keto you're about to
get the best blow up of your life you
don't stick to it you know what it is I
just realized I'm not eating enough
butter that's right it keeps her it
keeps your skin smooth it's not the
alcoholism or the smoking or the
gambling or wrecking cars I don't smoke
I don't drink alcohol so what do you
do
but
what are the best things ever yeah
um also I was surprised to find out and
you were laughing about on Chrissy's
show that you're you're into Asian dudes
and I thought that was weird
yeah
bro of course here's why we our producer
is Asian Frozen you still here
Frozen
Frozen Frozen
oh all right well I'll give up on Frozen
so check it out I can't he left what a
[ __ ] I changed smoke I chained smoke I
gamble I'm not much of a spitting on the
ground guy but I could learn you know
what I mean I could pick up that habit
no I have a I have a small penis I'm
just saying I see look you have to do
this you have to do this yeah this is
the easy part I can do this part that's
the easy part no but why is that why are
you a 35 year old weeb I don't I'm
trying to understand
I mean when I was a kid I mean that's
when like Sailor Moon was really popular
and stuff his old she's not lying when
she said 35 she's not [ __ ] with us
she dropped it right she dropped a
Sailor Moon round I like when you call
them old yeah are you nagging her no I'm
not nagging her you're an old lady for
for the internet we're dinosaurs I don't
even yeah that's the thing is is age
doesn't bother me the fact that I'm
getting older and all that doesn't
bother me at all I mean it's yeah oh wow
whoa the the hot chick who looks 25
doesn't occur she's getting older you
know it bothers me a lot okay it bothers
us a lot listen leave gam alone all
right she can't hold her right on her
[ __ ] she's got to soak her feet and
epsom salt every night oh butter Grandma
that's another good name
um
butter gilf butter gilf I like that
that's perfect all right
nah but I mean it we were we were
actually joking aside it's like what
Mercer's saying is true it's like it's
It's gotta hurt these [ __ ] when you
go on you're like you're just being a
[ __ ] stop being one you know I mean
obviously you say it nicer than that but
right that's that's the point and it's
like Oh shut the [ __ ] up what do you
know you don't it's like do you get a
lot you have to get a lot of hate DMS
right I get a ton of backlash and I've
been you know I've been in the like
gaming industry as a streamer and also
as a host for like I was on GameStop TV
I did some stuff with right okay but
real quick I'm sorry I didn't interrupt
you but your boy your Asian boyfriend's
not going to call and make you cry on
stream right because that would be
really I I unfortunately I don't have an
Asian boyfriend right now but you know
my DMs are open
um him on the [ __ ] phone just going I
will kill your [ __ ]
go get my crush
for real though it's like uh I I did
lose a ton of peers in the gaming
industry over a lot of my opinions uh
because it doesn't exactly follow like
the woke narrative politics and all that
stuff and when I was like hosting and
doing a lot of stuff like deep in the
industry and then I had to have a bit
more of a filter
and after like the cool stuff happened
all that I was like things are way out
of control I'm tired of just having to
be politically correct all the time I'm
just going to let more of my opinions
out there uh it started out more with
like speaking out against mandates and
stuff a certain poof mandates and what
state I'm sorry What state were you in
I'm just curious how the man is I'm in
Texas oh you're in Texas it wasn't that
bad for me it's five I think just the
The Narrative that a lot of other
streamers people in the gaming industry
were pushing on people were like get the
the Poke or you're a terrible person you
know I was going around everywhere and
people were getting guilt-tripped into
making medical decisions and that's a
terrible thing to do so I I was like hey
you know I have a platform and stuff and
I I want to be that one at least that
one person or a few in this industry who
can be a little more supportive to
people's decisions and so I did that I
made a tweet and I I was like you know I
I believe people should be able to make
a choice whether or not they want to get
that specific poke or not
um so don't let anybody guilt trip you
into it and man the canceled Brigade
hard that's how it started and then it's
kind of after that I was like hey you
know what heck like they've already
tried to cancel me I want to focus more
on just being independent an independent
Creator anyway and part of being an
independent Creator means that hey I
don't have to have this this filter this
politically correct filter anymore I can
just be open and be honest and has been
great I've been enjoying it yeah but but
now you probably have a bunch of dudes
like that look like Adam sessler and DM
screaming at you right oh I do the male
feminist is worse they are they really
probably has Adam Cecil yeah oh that's a
good point Adam sussman's right time all
day to yell everybody on Twitter luckily
I didn't get attacked by Adam sessler I
know he's come after a lot everybody
yeah he hasn't come after him he hasn't
said anything about your mom yet once
it's been a few years ago but when I met
him I had pink hair at that time so he
probably thought I was an ally to to the
low crowd I will say going back to your
point about them saying you know get get
the shot or you're a [ __ ] terrible
person and it's like all right but you
just spent four years calling me every
form of a terrible person I'm a Nazi and
a racist I'm homophobic I'm a rape
apologist and at this point I'm like
okay so like when it came down to like
just get it or you're a bad person I'm
like screaming I'm a bad person for four
years I think I'm kind of numb to it
that's where I'm at that's that's a good
point was leaning into it at this point
when they start yet Nazi like you that's
it you dropped your nuke nothing else
really matters I'm Charlie Kelly now I'm
answering my door in a [ __ ] full Nazi
regalia eating a banana yeah I'm like
I'm not getting it I'm sorry eat a stick
of butter it's better for your skin I'd
rather eat a stick of butter every day
than get the thing yeah good point right
oh yeah same and you have to be careful
obviously because you know YouTube is
still hitting people for that but yeah
it's it really it really is it really is
funny because
this whole world of allies like you said
especially like we know gamergate with
the gamer Community it's every everybody
in this game are coming it's they all
pretend to be friends and then the
moment one person steps out of line it's
like cancel this person
chicks with dresses are kind of funny
sometimes dudes and dresses are kind of
funny sometimes all right man and they
are I mean that was the foundation of
British comedy for like a hundred years
yeah I like to see a chap in a dress
that's a that's a ripping good time now
Melanie you once tweeted Frost is a
feminist icon what did you mean by that
oh that one maybe had a little too much
butter okay too much butter okay yeah
yeah that's it she just eats too much
butter and starts [ __ ] spiraling on
Twitter and yelling at people but but
you know like Keith olberman yeah
they're scared I mean thing is for me is
after all that and after I've already
spoken out and after I've already lost a
lot of peers and stuff and they canceled
me quote anyway even though I've only
you're doing you're doing better now
like always that's what always happens
yeah it does and uh after all that it's
like yeah I speak out on more stuff like
speaking of like don't be a hoe ladies
Let's uh let's have some dignity let's
have some self-respect stuff like that
it's like why I'm just gonna pop off on
anything I feel like at this point and
that's the one thing now I'm getting a
lot of backlash on and being called
internally misogynistic and all that
kind of stuff but the way I see it is I
would rather them see me that way and
hate on me that way
um and send out a better message
especially for younger girls out there
who are watching uh they're watching
streamers you see how like like the
younger boys they have a a bunch of
variety with girl or with guy streamers
to watch that they can relate to but
then with girls how what message does
that send to young girls when most
female streamers all have only fans
accounts you know it's like I don't
wanna I'm not just gonna be silent on
that I don't want I don't like how
people are encouraging and glorifying uh
that kind of work for girls and it's
also predatory on a lot of the guys who
partake in that to where it's like hey
they could be working on themselves they
could be hitting the gym they could be
working on their social skills and all
this stuff and instead here they are
feeling like they have a parasocial
relationship going on that's not real
they're just being used for their money
so it's just bad all around for
everybody first off you you use words
that are way too big for somebody that
will be on only fans so you'll you'll be
fine I've never seen someone only fans
also say parasocial in a sentence Yeah
well yeah
it's always some neckbeard that's like
hey leave it alone man she's empowered
right yeah okay of course they say that
because they want to benefit from it
they're like oh yeah sell your butt on
the internet for five dollars great
thank you wait a second that's less than
Netflix yeah
but it is true it's it's like and and
then I mean I I they may have been
kicked off but remember the only fans
posting their L's account oh yeah like
that was one of my favorites they might
have a new one but it was basically them
they're doing side-by-side shots of like
you know one girl being like make sure
uh be like you know it's just so lonely
why can't I find the right guy I just
want to lay here and cuddle with some of
the next one's like 18 and up only fans
I'm gonna be double dung and it was
another chick and you're like well
probably that's why I I did see there
was like a weird shift in tone from that
account though where it started getting
like really angry and yeah yeah it got
mad it's like there was one there was
one of the tweets I saw was this chick
that was literally like during the
pandemic yeah and she's like wow you
know I wish I could still do in-person
teaching instead of like [ __ ] you
know selling pictures of my tits for
money like at least my students and [ __ ]
respected me when I was teaching and
like they posted that screenshot and a
bunch of the replies were like sensible
people going yeah I don't know if this
is the oh you think it is this isn't
like one of those super [ __ ] this is
like literally during the [ __ ]
coverage shutdown yeah and obviously
this person's trying to survive and
they're actually expressing that it's
horrible and that they had no choice
like it was just kind of weird that the
the account started like it's like any
account when you do like a niche thing
then you have to find you have to seek
out every L and it's like sometimes
they're not quite the elves you're
trying to make it out to me you're like
sounds like a furloughed teacher that
got [ __ ] by their governor and like
you know had to figure out if you know
pay the bills so yeah I think there's
like checks and balances that need to be
in place like with this and anything
else of course is is some people can
overcompensate on the other side as well
um so for me it's just like obviously if
people are over here glorifying and
encouraging girls to be doing only fans
and stuff I don't like that because I
find that to be a predatory thing but I
think on the Other Extreme then some
people will just go after me or anybody
else any other girl for just like trying
to wear cute outfits or something wait
how can you say you're against only fans
in this but then you were a Crocker
that's a really good point
I will agree with that you'll see a lot
of that where it's like where it's like
you you have to be dressed like an Amish
woman if not you're immediately like the
really like really hard Trad
people it's one of those like oh my God
you're wearing a tank top to the gym
okay Trad horror but it's like yeah at
least people have to use their
imagination to fill in the blanks with
me seriously you know what I mean they
don't have like my entire butthole
mapped out in 3D I'm just wearing a
[ __ ] sports bra they still have to
[ __ ] imagine what my stuff looks like
yeah I'm not leaving a Hershey Kiss a
wet spot on every bench I sit on at the
gym that's the difference oh no mercy
it's because it's a butthole
um he didn't get it he doesn't get that
Chocolate Starfish Chocolate Starfish
seriously and the hot dog flavor you get
that you're 35.
um I keep forgetting no man you know
what I mean like you make references and
some be like oh I love the grassy I'm
like What's the grassy is that Canadians
saved by the belt
um
but yeah no it it is true and what what
did you that that's see you were in
gaming you for a while like you said
what did you think of that whole G4 TV
thing because I thought that was like
for me beautiful to watch it happen oh
yeah I mean I I think it's I think it's
a great example for hopefully that the
gaming industry as a whole can learn
from and I think we're seeing it just in
the entertainment space in general is
you know the saying get whoa go broke
like it's true and I think a lot of
companies people lose sight of that
because they just look at Twitter and
Twitter has a ton of bots but even
beyond that even the actual people who
are promoting a lot of the garbage that
isn't successful uh and getting a ton of
likes it might get like a hundred
thousand likes on a on a tweet about
this or that defending this or that but
then it actually won't perform well so
it's just saying that people these woke
people who are pushing all this stuff
and trying to defend all this stuff
they're not supporting it so hey maybe
stop trying to appeal to to you know a
sect of people on Twitter and listen to
actual Gamers on what we like to see
with content in general and with our
game our games too because those are
getting woke washed like crazy I do
worry about that man because I you know
I already heard I mean I'm not going to
judge you because in Kamaya but I've
already heard stuff about the new GTA
coming out and and it's gonna it's gonna
be less it's what they do with Saints
Row it's gonna be less you know whatever
and there's going to be a woke plot in
it and I'm sure there's going to be some
sort of trans person but it's going to
be the hero I don't know man if you go
back to the basics like I just remember
GTA 3 coming out back in the day and
being like wait there's a gamer you
could just shoot at the police yeah okay
I'm in I've never had I've never
experienced shooting at a cop before and
I sure don't want to try that in the
real move to Chicago
I mean the beauty of uh of GTA is that
it was always supposed to be offensive
like that was the fun part of it it was
supposed to offend everybody and I think
it's you know similar to how South Park
is for example go ahead offend people
that's part of the fun of this game but
it's a game where you literally assault
hookers and cars back people like how is
that that should be offensive I think if
we're gonna go like well this is
offensive shouldn't the mere concept of
oh it's a game where you write Bookers
car check people and shoot at the police
but hey are you good enough there's not
enough bypoc representation that's the
real controversy the new Hunter bidens
him sounds fun I gotta try it out
oh they've had a kids one the Ashley
bidens him yeah I know right no one's
talking about that one anymore huh
that's kind of weird
are you are you are you into
conspiracies or are you just a little
bit Yeah I dabble I dabble oh you dabble
like Stuttering John
um what to what is what is what is one
of the conspiracy theories you get the
most [ __ ] for
probably I think the
think they have a known Benjamin on our
hands
um Van Allen belts wait Virgie thinks
the moon landing was faked right
absolutely 100 see
it was it was felt I'm like 50 50 on
that one I've never really been it's
like someone
that you're actually seeing AR
technology you see them like moving
something and all of a sudden the filter
goat messes up and it's gone or somebody
thinking that they're moving something
because they're seeing it Stanley
Kubrick did his best okay he did his
best look Sandy Kubrick didn't have a
great CGI at the time a bunch of other
movies he was making and he was trying
to help the government out as well what
did you want the guy to do okay he has
limited technology Michael Bay would
have nailed it okay is what I'm saying
same film on location that's the problem
that's true they wouldn't that's why
James Cameron wouldn't do it because it
would only go to space yeah and Zack
Snyder should have done it because we
had all those solar flares yeah but then
nobody would have seen it
um but but so the moon landing one
that's a good one I I think that the uh
what about the tower seven when you do
dabble in 8911 Tower seven stuff oh I I
think that was an inside job that whole
thing and I think that like George W
Bush was behind it all that stuff I may
not understand like the super deep
conspiracies around it but I do I do
think 911 was an inside job look
building seven just fell okay sometimes
a bunch of copy paper is burning in a
steel concrete building and in the
burning copy paper can really melt those
beams yeah but what about the Plastics
oh what about the plastic staplers
all those all those burning swing lines
took down a whole [ __ ] Sky you know
how hot it takes to melt the paper clip
um
yeah I mean that that one that one's one
where I kind of think most people would
kind of have a silent agreement that
something funky went on at this point
like I don't think there's anybody that
legitimately this day could actually buy
the official 911 narrative anymore I
think there's no way right
I wouldn't think so but but they've also
conditioned us they actually want us to
not believe in like 9 11 and JFK stuff
because they want us to just get used to
it like they want us to just get used to
being [ __ ] in the ass and doing
nothing about it yeah that's a really
good point hey how come you don't have
how come how come you don't support
trans Gamers better you should because
once it's met with the president yeah
aren't you on Twitch and you'd be uh
buddying up with that [ __ ] dear woman
yeah oh that dear one yeah what was her
name a Bambi I forget her name but
whatever videos of that person being
like yeah oh that was wild what are you
doing and they're like I'm in charge now
I guess we should have waited too around
to talk about this but we actually were
mentioning this one Dylan uh Mulvaney
this one this person this lovely lady
[ __ ] it looks like Dylan McDermott
[Music]
[Laughter]
I hope Dylan roof was waiting outside
um that's [ __ ] up if he is I got some
Burger King for him it's on me this time
um but anyway we were talking about this
actually the first hour and it's like we
were saying and after saying it's Marie
for Breaking Bad she does look like
Marie from Breaking Bad holy [ __ ] down
to the outfits
holy [ __ ] they're minerals Marie no no
no no no you know what it is they're
minerals foreign
but look it's wow that's all I see [ __ ]
it's gonna [ __ ] me up now and that's a
shame because it's it's [ __ ] up
because the actress who plays Marie is
not a bad look he does but it's true
it's funny that this does kind of look
like
so we were talking about this and I
guess we should have probably waited to
ask a girl but we were saying that at
least to our opinion like when trans
people used to try at least they're not
even trying anymore and I was like if
I'm a woman I'm so [ __ ] pissed
because you guys can even try to look
like us anymore
yeah I mean I I I agree with that I
think it's it's getting to ridiculous
levels like I'm totally fine being
supportive and using the right pronouns
if if they're legitimately really trying
uh you know you see people like Blair
white uh great dude I to me I see her
okay I like that's just my initial not
her like she put in the effort to
transition and she presents herself that
way but I think when it comes to this
sending this message that uh you know
while on one hand it's like it that's
the thing is is anything like the woke
movement uh pushes forward a lot of
times comes through a trojan horse and
so in the case of hey we want to say you
don't have to perfectly transition
because it's easier for some than others
and we'll still see you as a woman and
blah blah blah like okay that sounds all
nice and all but there's dangers that
come with that uh you see just with like
sports for example uh dudes that are
just able to say I identify as a woman
not have to do any sort of transition
and be able to participate in uh female
sports
um you know especially the fighting
where you're actually putting women at
harm here but even beyond that if I
think of just using a public restroom
for example now if I were to be in the
women's bathroom and someone like Blair
white who very much presents as a woman
and put in a lot of effort to transition
that's she's not going to bother me
being there but as some dude who puts no
effort in there and just says I identify
as woman it is right there that's that's
dangerous that's not safe yeah I gotta
say if I'm in a bathroom and Blair
White's in there like I'm gonna try to
sneak a peek right we're gonna wanna you
have to kind of Wonder you know
guarantees probably bigger than you two
you know you know that's how it goes too
obviously
you know that's what always happens the
[ __ ] logo the draw you just run into
play in the bathroom and you're like
come on come on let's see it
you're the reason the trans people don't
feel safe in bathrooms not good because
I don't want them in my bathroom oh fair
enough
oh it's funny uh Lauren Southern uh
Southern she made a tweet earlier about
this Dylan person and uh and she said
Lauren said I'm going to start the
female version of Dylan Mulvaney uh day
75 of being a man haha having gone to
therapy once literally been assaulting
women and eating protein powder haha
it's just like these extreme characters
oh yeah that's all they do I mean it's
it's but it's blackface it's the same
thing you're taking what these you
there's more to a woman it's like it's
like going like look guy let's listen
here Al Jolson there's more to a black
guy than black face painting like a
white ring around their mouth it's like
there's more to women than wearing a
[ __ ] dress big giant painted on red
lips
what are you doing are you even crying
it's that's what it just feels like oh
okay so at any moment I could just be
whatever I want but what's [ __ ]
insane now is in this I'm gonna play a
little clip of this
she gets to talk to the president my
221st day of publicly transitioning I
love it
I'm not even awake
I don't even want to look at it
he's
state that allows me access to the
resources I need and that decision is
California I'm assuming I'm going to
assume California here guys I'm taking a
shot in the dark but yeah Cali Joe Biden
once went before the Senate and was
talking about like a bill about like you
know whatever it was like lower income
like disadvantaged communities remember
that speech yeah when he's like yeah you
say their disadvantaged Community but
they're out there banging you know my
cousin or my wife over the head and
taking things they're robbing people and
doing hardly going off about black
people we've gone from that Joe Biden to
like you're 80. that's nice I'm tired
it's elder abuse at this point to put
him uh on camera is this the lady that
gives me the sponge bath
me and my doctors no that's Ashley
that was very funny but also
ouch but many states have lawmakers that
feel like they can involve themselves in
this very personal process
do you we want State funds we want State
money we want State support but we also
want you to get involved look lady I
know for saying this to a trans person
is hard but pick a lane yeah that's the
equivalent of telling your job like I
want you to keep cutting me a check yeah
I just don't want to come in anymore and
that's what we call a public high school
teacher oh that's true I think States
should have a right to ban gender
affirming Health Care no no but here's
the problem is that what you just said
is the opposite of how this
constitutional republic was constructed
so you can't say states don't have a
right to things because States and
rights are kind of the whole Foundation
of this thing you dumb [ __ ] hey look
you are kind of like a woman
um no offense to the one getting better
and better by the day
she's secretly stalking Melanie's
Twitter account every day okay eat
sputter check
hey stupid do you realize that when
states have rights that means that
you'll always have a sanctuary to run to
but if you make the federal government
in charge of everything then they'll
just decide they don't like you you know
what someday and maybe they'll just want
to start [ __ ] really genociding you
and then you're like oh God I have
nowhere to run to because we let the
federal government at least in this case
Florida or whatever oh Alabama doesn't
like trans people all right we'll move
two states over Dude You're Gonna you
know move to Atlanta or move to
Louisiana yeah move somewhere where they
go oh yeah we don't mind you so much
here right but no let the federal
government just rule on everything that
won't ever backfire ever
I think it will
but it is funny man it's it's like this
this is the issue like you know I will
agree with with the fact of and we've
I've always said this is like man when
you become an adult if you want to be
trans that's all you man do whatever you
want to do I don't care but like this is
the sticking point for me which he's
about to say now this whole this gender
affirming care and you can't block
puberty that's insane like well no you
can no I know you can't without
repercussion like we can and we will
yeah
so that's the part you know it's like oh
so you want the government to stop you
know basically castrating kids yeah
that'd be cool yeah that'd be great
thank you and that's why I kind of get
mad sometimes like with certain people
like and we've even seen it like in our
chat sometimes where people like have no
sympathy for these like trans people
that are like 20 but they were like
transitioning when they were 16 and it's
like you got to have a little empathy
for them they got [ __ ] brainwashed
dude right of course you know what I
mean it's like yeah but they were just
teenage like all the [ __ ] I wanted to do
to myself when I was a teenager my
mother just didn't allow it and like I
had friends that were just already had a
bunch of tats and [ __ ] by the time they
were 17 and I was like all really good
tattoos my mother was like I'll [ __ ]
literally murder you and you know then
you grow obviously man obviously Melanie
said it well
then you grow up and you don't have bad
like Sublime tattoos and [ __ ] you know
what I mean like you grow up you go you
know what I'm glad my mom didn't let me
get an eyebrow ring because now I don't
look like a [ __ ] like a Puerto Rican
Barber with a [ __ ] piece of my
eyebrow missing yeah you're the only guy
with a 40 ounces of Freedom tattoo I
promise but that's what I mean back then
that's the kind of dumb [ __ ] I would
have gotten yeah right and it's like now
it's like no no forget about tattoos you
want to cut your dick off right due to
peer pressure insane
a really good point like and I look back
as I kind of feel like an old man and
we're about the same age but like an old
man when you think back you're like man
if somebody tried this like you know
this [ __ ] when I was a kid it would have
been hell would have broken loose and
now it's just like uh actually we do
have to give hormone blockers a kid
because if not you're a Nazi oh okay
that seems fair that's a fair compromise
sure I guess you know and they always
give you these impossible positions like
none of us are really Nazis but well
maybe Virgie but none of us besides
Verge are really Nazis I'm not okay and
sure Virgie me I'm sorry Neo I was I was
waiting I was waiting for like the the
artistic like oh actually I'm a national
Soldier
oh [ __ ] but none of you are but then if
you give me the choice between like
we're going to castrate children you're
going to call your Nazi but like I guess
you have to call me a Nazi I don't know
yeah because I will not be supporting
children getting mutilated just not
going to happen yeah you're making me
choose between racist homophobe or child
groomer so it's like at this point uh
I'm real comfortable in the first time
already I was already the first option
before you showed up I'm already I
already got all my little [ __ ] you
know like uh slurs and [ __ ] already
locked and loaded I feel like really at
39 to switch horses at this Midstream
like this is probably not the best I'm
not saying I'm a racist but I could
recite Eddie Murphy's raw stand up by
memory and I do often on subways
sometimes in a sleep yeah it's really
weird uh that was first rated R movie
ever saw that's why we always have to
book hotels with good thick walls it's
true it is true
shouting the n-word in a [ __ ] Roadway
Inn that's not good it's gonna get
everybody killed why are right away in
bro all right sorry we're not we're
really not This Racist all the time
um just most of the time Healthcare I
don't think anything's like yeah we're
not usually This Racist everybody's just
trying to impress yeah we're in our best
behavior actually we're in our best
behavior because we're being extra
racist everybody's trying to impress
Ed
I don't like them the more hey Melanie
look
they checked your stuff out we just read
all the things the all the people that
hate you on Reddit said and my
assumptions are you love racist stuff
you're Neo-Nazi and you want to genocide
people that's what I was told that's
what I mean that that sounds perfect got
my bio accurate yeah in your [ __ ] Gap
bio wait are you not any of those things
because I already made you a valentine
oh no I wasted all this money at
Michael's it was a train it was a
cartoon train going to Auschwitz it said
I choo choo choose you I mean I'm
sitting here I was [ __ ] I was hot
gluing [ __ ] fake pearls
and now for nothing she's not even
really racist
is that why you came with a box of
macaroni that's why he showed up with
macaroni and glitter
oh [ __ ] no but seriously they're trying
to castrate kids guys
[ __ ] this is where we're at but a
million years it's super [ __ ] weird
like and we're just doing it now and
it's just normal and it's fine and
nobody cares to do that and I think even
it comes to adults obviously they should
be able to make the decision they want
to make or they can find a doctor
willing to do it but we shouldn't be
encouraging that no I I you know I don't
care if you know they want to transition
all that but I don't think we should be
encouraging mutilating their genitals
because that's there's just so many
complications that come with that and
it's not going to give them the genitals
they actually want anyway it's just a
transformed version that kind of looks
similar it's not the same well we don't
have to encourage people to to mutilate
their bodies what they do they're going
to do but we shouldn't encourage it well
they're doing the same thing like it
always happens I remember the abortion
thing even the Democrats were like safe
legal and rare and most people like okay
well safe legal and rare sounds
reasonable and then it was like
everything up until 10 months after
they're born and like okay that's a
little ridiculous and that's the same
thing here where you're like okay look
we understand that the degender
dysmorphia is I do believe gender
dysmorphia is a real thing yeah and I do
really believe that some this but but
the truth of the matter is if you really
look at the the studies like with
therapy here over time people tend to
break out of that like body dysmorphi
like an eating disorder like anything
like that you could break out of it but
you know even workout people can get
psychotic oh yeah you're like you're
entirely too large now and they're
injecting Synthol into their arms
they're like okay this is getting you
have a problem you're not seeing what we
see which is that you're already a
[ __ ] man Mountain you don't have to
injecting [ __ ] into you dude stop yeah
but I'm gonna transition into a girl now
[ __ ]
uh the only exception of like the Mr
Olympia guys oh that's his job because
they know what they're doing is
unhealthy yeah like your International
bodybuilder guys I got three
competitions in me and then I gotta stop
or I'm gonna [ __ ] up but you know what's
funny it's funny you say that because
the healthy thing is a great point it's
like I can't imagine you're waking up
taking hormones from an opposite sex and
all these different pills and you have
these huge scars under your chest and
stuff like that and you go this is
healthy this is what a healthy person
does like
I mean I don't even want to take 20
pills you know what I mean so it just
seems like okay so everything about you
and I'm not saying this to be a dick but
everything is synthetic the drugs are
synthetic everything you you know your
penis is synthetic like everything isn't
so when does when do you when do you
just stop being a person and just start
being a robot you know right yeah I mean
it's it's a tough type of thing that
they have to go through and I can
sympathize that oh man that's sad they
gotta feel they have to struggle with
that dysmorphia but uh to be glorifying
or gender dysphoria is just absurd we
shouldn't be glorifying it if anything I
in an ideal situation we could encourage
people to like love themselves how they
are and how they were born that's the
ideal scenario well hear me out because
I got a great idea trivia because now
we're pivoting so we're pivoting again
we're going to help you out because
butter babe we got it we can help you
out if we're doing this for a while
here's what you do you transition not
really but you do listen hear me go I
love the Melvin Mack Arc for you okay
Melvin is a great name already you don't
have to change a lot of stuff because
you like a really good theatrical like
level fake mustache yeah yeah it's Gotta
Be Like You could twirl it and that'll
be your whole new thing okay and you're
always cleaning butter out of it I
really like this for you then they're
gonna let you back on any streaming
platform you want and because you're
trans now and you could be one of the
deer people like we said
I will be immune to criticism Perfect
Look by the way ten thousand noodles
earlier says I did ask like does she
ever have like I don't know like
pancakes or like a potato with her
butter or just no no because
Amazon and not all the time but as a
treat does have actually good keto flour
for pancakes with almond flour and it's
not bad so okay you know you can't have
it all the time right it's pretty much
almond browsing recommendation it's not
bad it's both no no she knows what I
mean I know what you mean yeah because
we do tend to miss uh stuff like pizza
pancakes yeah cake stuff like that so
whenever you can find an alternative
it's nice you have sometimes once in a
while then yeah it's great and it's it's
always it's always great to see somebody
that's infinitely better shape talking
about you know how this diet plan is so
difficult it's uh okay you know what 35
it's whatever I don't care we age very
poorly immersed we made terrible
lifestyle decisions honestly I'm I've
aged poorly depending on who I'm looking
at that's a really good you know what I
mean like yeah okay with her on the
screen I look like [ __ ] but but when
James Robert Clark is on the screen I
feel like a [ __ ] stud but when you
look at this you feel great
there's some people like you see uh like
on TV and stuff too and you find out
that you're your age and you're like wow
okay I'm not doing too bad then hey what
was your favorite part of the She-Hulk
twerking scene mine was when she twerked
that whole show was such a thing [ __ ]
nightmare that show was it'll be back oh
of course it'll my girl will be back you
think she'll be back to working in CGI
yeah you know who was in it speaking of
trans women who's actually really funny
Patty Harrison was in an episode from I
think you should leave and by the way
that show sucks she's the funniest thing
in that episode did you watch did you
watch the show was she the uh the white
the bride yes yeah I didn't even know
she was
transcended with uh Tim Robinson like
Royce was the one that was like you
believe he's trans I looked her up
because I was like she's a really fur I
go for a chick she's really funny and
then it turns out she was a dude and it
made sense so so it made sense why she's
funny that's why but she is the funniest
part of the show every time I meet a
funny chick I just lift her skirt up oh
FYI merch you haven't checked you
haven't seen her yet since the last time
you saw her boob job Patty Harrison has
a boob job
she got new ones put in well you know
sometimes you got to get some uh some
Snap-on some bolt-ons it's not bolt
times you don't call them ball towns
that's very disrespectful okay
all right
they're called attention Seekers yes
um I believe is the term is a term for
that
um
but uh I mean I don't I think that's all
we got for today huh we're pretty much
done yeah we gotta do a live reading
stuff yeah
yeah I guess hey Melanie is there
anything you want to talk about we could
talk about whatever you want
quick what's top of mind what did you
talk about today on Twitter uh today on
well on my YouTube channel I talked
about the whole Bayonetta three drama
going on I don't know do you guys play
video games yes I do but explain to me
the drama I've been playing video games
though okay so this is what happened all
right so bayonetta's original voice
actress last week went on Twitter made a
video and said hey I was only offered
four thousand dollars to voice the
entire game of Bayonetta three and I
turned it down and I think we need to
boycott uh the game don't buy it because
uh you know they didn't offer pay me
enough and they need to pay people
better and so then that's all she had to
say and got like 200 000 likes on that
tweet a ton of people were immediately
ready to cancel Bayonetta three and then
some more receipts came out and turns
out she lied she got caught of course
okay lying that she was actually offered
fifteen thousand dollars and yeah it was
just a bunch of
of course of course attention seeking
again I don't understand and by the way
listen lady man I'm I I got [ __ ] I
only got paid like 200 bucks to voice
that character but the Fallout thing
yeah you really did get [ __ ] oh my God
huh you should do it you oh to be fair
it was for a mod it wasn't for a [ __ ]
AAA company or anything but 15 000 by
the way look I know there's a lot of
Hardcore Bayonetta fans but let's be
honest man this is kind of a niche game
okay it is yeah that is more of a like
you have to have everyone only somebody
who has a switch and [ __ ] funko pop
dolls really into it it's Devil May Cry
for women right that's why they cry for
women it's perfect that's the best
description bayonet of three women do
cry
they like it
by the way lady you you understand that
it's a voice work all you have to do is
find millions of people that could do
great voice working you could be
replacing like two seconds oh yeah oh my
God Jennifer Hale to do it she's a very
popular voice actress but the thing is
though is um you know she didn't have to
like their offer and that's totally fine
if she didn't like it if she thinks
she's worth more and didn't take it but
to call for boycott it's just ridiculous
dude that one that one's [ __ ] it's
such an easy job too like I know I'm a
[ __ ] and I've done voiceover work in my
own Studio like with no oversight
it's not that hard you know what I mean
yeah by the way how many Funko poplars
do you have
I only have like
10 at the most oh that's close don't get
any more you're a weirdo we're gonna
start veering into quartering territory
that's too many
I have a life-size Lara Croft statue
right here oh but that's like wait which
Laura Croft the classics oh okay yeah
that's fine then that's based hell yeah
the new one ain't Lara Croft she's a
ripoff no no that's that stuff I want
the classic PS1 one with the cone boots
fine she's the best one she's iconic I'm
gonna post the comb one and be like
women what's stopping you from looking
like this
I don't know a better gaming card I
guess
all right you're a gamer what are you
playing right now
oh gosh right now I'm playing a lot more
retro stuff so uh got like a tube TV oh
you found like the local classifieds
cool so I can get like a a tube TV and
uh got my PS1 connected to that been
playing uh old school Tomb Raider and uh
danger girl it hurts my soul
that now we have to say I was playing a
retro game on a PS1 right is when I
think retro I think I was playing an NES
game you know right and it's like PS1 is
considered a retro
what's your favorite PS1 title that no
one's heard of oh that no one's heard oh
my gosh one that like you bring it up
and like no one's ever [ __ ] got it
well I know danger girl doesn't have a
lot of people didn't know about that no
um I don't know about that what is that
yeah danger girl is like a a comic book
series by J Scott Campbell back in the
late 90s early 2000s and it basically
has like these hot like spy chicks type
oh I'm looking at the cover yeah yeah
and
um and there's a they have a video game
for it too and it's basically like a
great value Tomb Raider meets a great
value Perfect Dark so it's you know was
not a perfect game but I like it bro
this just got some robbed lifefield
Vibes on the on the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
you see that hold on let me pull it up
it's it's got some I'm gonna fix that uh
where is there I [ __ ] hate this
stupid thing
ah whatever give me a second
okay that should fix it
um I [ __ ] hate OBS I don't know if
you use OBS but it [ __ ] sucks
um there it is danger go that is like
some 90s comic Vibe that's like some
that was some Pamela Anderson barbed
wire Vibe you know right which is great
yeah uh I love it I love the like Femme
fatal Trope that doesn't really exist
anymore but no all women are powerful
women are all women are powerful and can
beat up guys that's the new thing now
yeah trans women well but the thing is
now they're not allowed to be hot though
it's like yeah I saw She-Hulk I saw
She-Hulk yeah dumpy they can beat up
dudes but they can't be hot and they um
they have to have a chip on their
shoulder and have the most insufferable
personality like that's the new he just
basically described the [ __ ] female
version of Seth Rogen yeah I mean that's
funny that's what they want okay Virgie
what's your what's your most weird PS1
game then what was yours oh my most
weird PS1 game oh God
PaRappa the racist that only came out in
China yeah actually that's I play it all
the time it's weird you don't actually
rap you just kind of Shout At Large
crowds of people oh that's not great
that's not great all right we are coming
up to the MLA thank you so much for
being on we really do appreciate it I'll
plug your [ __ ] thank you uh yeah you
guys can follow me on social media
everywhere at Melanie Mack that's on
Twitter Instagram uh all all that stuff
and then on YouTube Melanie Mac Go Boom
Melanie man go boom okay uh I'm posting
it in the chat big Plucky Duck fan from
tinytoons
I for those of you people that are
completely uh you know stupid and won't
do it because they're lazy There's the
link is in the chat hey Melanie thank
you so much for coming on you are more
than welcome to come on whatever you'd
like just let us know thank you I had a
lot of fun we'll hang out we'll braid
each other's hair we'll talk about boys
we'll eat butter yeah perfect you guys
can identify as women for that like
let's go look I don't want to flex on
anybody but listen you hang out with us
I got the best Lando Lakes okay they
make it here in Lando Lakes okay it's
fresh okay it's right but thank you so
much for being on and you can get the OG
stuff like the stuff that still has the
India I need the native woman on the
boxer I don't want it so yeah the new
ones have her as a blackjack dealer but
yeah pretty much
Jesus [ __ ] thank you so much Melanie
thank you so much we really appreciate
it all right I hope you come on again
yeah absolutely all right take it easy
bye and There She Goes Melanie Max she
was fun very lovely very lovely it's
very fun view came back now you piece of
[ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know Frozen really is the funniest
out of all I hate you frozen you [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] blew it
God I never thought I'd say this but if
I could just be Asian for one one day
bro one day